mais justement compagnie solide
j'suis con connu leur fait confiance ce
n'est pas un film mais de nombreux films
québécois qui sont présentées à berlin
dans le cadre du festival international
qui présentement en cours de nombreux
québécois vont y présenter un film
souvent en première mondiale et c'est le
code du tout nouveau film de denis côté
xing son onzième long métrage qui se
retrouvent en compétition officielle
dont parmi les dix sept films en
compétition officielle cette année
ça s'intitule répertoire des villes
disparu s'est librement inspiré du roman
du même titre écrit par laurence olivier
qui a été publié en 2015 on retrouve
dans ce film là vous le reconnaissez
jean michel anctil robert naylor qu'on
avait découvert dans le film d'ici ni de
podz jean michel anctil diane lavallée
le tournage a eu lieu l'hiver dernier en
montérégie dans quelques villages pour
créer le village fictif dirait ni les
neiges et ses 215 habitat donc il ya eu
un accident de voiture un homme est mort
les circonstances on et bühler tout
village se demande ce qui s'est passé il
ya des étrangers dans la vie lontan de
comprendre comment ça se fait que tout
s'est passé aussi mal que ça et denis
côté explique pourquoi encore une fois
un de ses films se déroule à l'extérieur
d'une grande ville et montréal mois
oui mais on m'envoie régulièrement
d'heure ah oui c'est ça
dams souvent notamment pourquoi tout est
fait mais ça passe dans la morale moi
j'ai une personne très urbaine
tu me lâches région puis pour moi c'est
comme un champ des possibles absolue
c'est là qu'ont fait ces terres coup
c'est là qu'on cache de sacrés terrible
comme je connais pas bien la région pour
moi je la mythifie beaucoup plus
facilement c'est là que je me sens plus
créatif c'est un jeune qui parle de
québec d'aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on est
en 5 6 millions
le québécois francophones
anglophone je trouve que j'ai caché dans
le film un peu un sous texte sur
l'immigration sur notamment à la mort au
deuil et où chaque personnage et denis
côté qu'une belle relation avec ce
festival c'est sa cinquième présence sa
troisième présence en compétition
officielle donc on lui souhaite bonne
chance cette année la présidente du jury
il pourra donc séduire juliette binoche
donc elle sera occupée avec ses dix sept
longs métrages qui sont en compétition
officielle et on s'intéresse à la parité
est de plus en plus dans les festivals
partiellement les festivals en europe
puisque les principaux directeurs des
festivals à cannes à venise ont signé
des engagements pour plus de parité
homme femme à la fois dans les films que
l'on présente mais également dans
l'organisation des festivals cette année
donc à berlin
41% des films qui sont en compétition
officielle sont réalisés par des femmes
c'est beaucoup plus que les autres
festivals en europe à cannes l'année
dernière cette année 2010 est à venir
seulement 5% dont 41% beaucoup mieux que
les autres festivals en mieux et puis il
ya d'autres films québécois qui sont
présentés dans le cadre du festival
oui notamment le premier long métrage de
fiction avec s'intitule une colonie de
geneviève du lieu de 2 celle qui a pris
l'affiché environ une semaine et vous
voyez les jeunes comédiens dans ce film
qui sont déjà sur place qui vont pouvoir
discuter avec un jeune public puisque ce
film une colonie présenté dans la
sélection génération ka plus donc pour
adolescents vont pour discuter avec lui
recueillir leurs commentaires c'est
l'histoire d'une adolescente qui a de la
misère à trouver sa place à la maison et
à l'école et qui avec ses amis vont
réussir justement a retrouvé un petit
peu c'est un repère lire le cinéaste
pascal plante également qui est membre
du jury dans une autre catégorie pour
adolescents mais avec des films un petit
peu plus avertis l'année dernière son
film les faux tatouages avait été
présenté au festival du film de berlin
il ya plusieurs courts métrages
également qui seront proposés cette
année quatre courts métrages québécois
notamment aux corbeaux aux corbeaux qui
va être présenté en première mondiale
donc j'ai hâte de voir ce qui va se
passer avec denis côté on va le savoir
dans une semaine c'est à ce moment là
qu'on va décerner les prix ce serait un
bon coup de pub lice
et c'est à ce moment là que répertoire
des villes disparu pour être diffusé en
salles chez nous dans un peu moins d'une
semaine
excellent merci pour ce résumé